David Cameron was right when he said
that kidnapper a kidnap ransoms they go
towards buying arms they go towards
funding terrorist activities and they
and they fundamentally push forward the
terrorists agenda and that's exactly
what we don't want to do not only that
if you become known as the country who
pays ransoms then no national from your
country will ever be safe again so how
do you go about securing the release of
a hostage in a situation like this we
know that David Cameron has said that
he's going to personally supervise all
the efforts to do just that so what kind
of strategy can you have well he's going
to look at all of his options he's going
to talk to his military and intelligence
people and figure out if there's a way
of learning the location of the hostage
and of either rescuing him or somehow
disrupting the terrorists operations
he's going to look at the any kind of
diplomatic avenues where there might be
contacts with ISIL through a third party
of some kind but paying the ransom is
normally the very wrong thing to do in
this kind of case what will come onto
the prospect of a possible rescue but
you talked about diplomatic channels is
that possible you have great deal
experience of negotiating hostage
release is how likely our negotiations
in a situation like this with a group
like Islamic state well unfortunately
it's not likely but you can't not do it
just because it's unlikely you're going
to try every single thing that you can
think of and more in order to secure the
safe release of the hostage however
because we're dealing with an unusual
group in ISIL they don't want money they
want some kind of political concessions
that neither mr. Obama or Mr Cameron a
willing or should make well no I look at
the big picture it's interesting then to
work out what their motives are for
these videos that they've been posting I
mean in all honestly they aren't going
to believe that countries such as the US
or the UK going to change their
fundamental strategy as a result of that
video are they what are they trying to
achieve well well you're right Anna what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to scare people they're trying to scare
the the population the voters into may
be forcing politicians into making a
hasty or and on ill-judged move that
will then play into isil's hands but at
the end of the day as your previous
feature was saying that ISIL is our
experts in manipulating the the media
and the and social media as well they
want to get their message out and this
is a terrific way of getting people to
pay attention it attracts attention
certainly but what role do you think it
plays in succeeding to radicalize other
potential people to their cause I mean
given the brutality of the videos does
it really act as a recruitment tool well
I think it's going to retract attract as
a recruitment tool to a certain fringe
element of people who for the most part
or Fanta cysts and not really going to
do anything in particular but they find
this kind of stuff somehow attractive
and satisfying and so you know that's
simply what's going to you know that's
simply what's going to happen for any
kind of mccobb a video like that but the
opposite is true as well you have just
as many if not more people who are
repulsed by it and who are completely
against it and we know that the security
forces are doing their best to identify
at the person who is masked in the video
the apparent killer of the two mara con
hostages so far it has a British accent
if they were to identify that person how
significant a breakthrough would that be
unfortunately I don't think it would be
much a significant very significant in a
larger sense certainly be satisfying
from a perspective from the perspective
of the UK public and and certain perhaps
from the Foley's and salt lost families
but at the end of the day uh the the
people who were chosen by ISIL to do the
lower-level jobs like guarding guarding
prisoners and hostages tend to be the
British jihadists because they don't
have the religious credentials or the
military background that say Chechens
might or other nationalities would and
similarly obviously they're trying to
trace the location as well is that more
useful potentially in terms of planning
a potential rescue indeed it might yeah
if they could locate the place to
graphically they can extrapolate from
that in terms of well how long can you
drive in a car you know in a radius of
and the types of roads and they can do a
pretty good job of narrowing down in
areas of square miles and square
kilometers where they are but if it's in
a built-up area if it's in an urban area
then it's going to be very difficult
because it's going to be next to
impossible to find them in an urban area
and you've got experience of kidnaps
from around the world how would you
assess this compared to other cases that
you've seen how much more challenging is
this hostage situation than others well
cases like this political or
ideologically motivated cases like this
are more difficult and more risky to the
hostage then say economic or kidnaps for
ransom and the reason for that is is
that ransom meant to kidnap for ransom
or simply done for the money the
kidnappers are doing it for the money
but I so obviously sure they would like
to have the millions that other others
have paid but at the end of the day
they're also getting lots of free
publicity they're getting their
political message out there it's working
for them from a recruitment perspective
and so what they're what they want is
and what their demands were in the
earlier cases was for the United States
to stop bombing them but they're smart
enough to know that that's not going to
happen as you said and so the point is
is that what they really want out of
this is the publicity the
sitive publicity is what they want and
how dangerous would you say that it was
for people from Britain from America to
go to this part of the world what would
your advice be to anyone considering
that I would absolutely not go not for
your own sake but for the sake of your
family for the sake of your neighbors
for the sake of your friends this is
waffen worse on the families and the
friends than it is on the individuals
who are who are abducted the families
suffer the most that's usually the case
in this kind of situation